- We have reached the end of the hour,
but I have one more
uplifting story to share.
This is "What I'm Liking."
(upbeat music)
A baby calf in Australia
is bringing smiles
to people worldwide.
And that is because he was born
with a literal smile on his coat.
Take a look.
- [Audience] Aw.
- That's incredible.
It's a real smiley face on the bull calf.
That's incredible.
Of course, there was only
one name to give him, Happy.
Even better, Happy was sold for charity
and will live out his days on a farm.
We have Happy on the line from Australia,
along with his new owner
of Farm World, Craig,
watching on 7Bravo.
Oh my God, this is amazing.
(audience applauds)
Oh my gosh, so-
- G'day, Kelly.
- It's unbelievable even when
you see it live in person.
Okay, so this was a win-win for everybody,
especially Happy, right?
- A hundred percent, Kelly.
As you can see, he's got a beautiful
happy smiling face on his torso.
He was born down in Southeast
Australia in Victoria
and the reality is we kind of stepped in
once they took a photo and
it went a bit viral on them.
They're farmers and they didn't
want the media attention,
but we run a big major event space here
and a big event called
Farm World every year.
Happy was the star of the show.
And we got 300 acres of
beautiful green rolling hills
in Gippsland for him to
play with and to munch on.
So he's gonna have a wonderful life
for many years to come as our mascot.
And these markings on his torso
are just gonna grow with him
and get stronger and stronger.
So yeah, really pleased to have him.
- Oh, my gosh, he's beautiful.
And Happy helped raise money
for the hospital there, right?
- Yeah, he did.
So Megan and Barry
basically donated him to us
and we made a donation
to the local hospital
for 10,000 Australian dollars, US $7,000,
to be able to host Happy on the property
for the next 20, 25 years,
that's how long it'll go.
And the local hospital picked up
a fantastic donation for Happy.
And so it's a win-win for everybody.
Happy gets a beautiful life
on the green rolling
pastures of Gippsland.
Megan and Barry have
made a fantastic donation
with our support as Lardner Park
and Farm World, our big event
and the hospital gets
to enjoy the donation
and put that money to great use.
Megan and Barry's kids
were born at the hospital
and it really supports
our agricultural community
here in Victoria, in Gippsland.
- Wow, it really is a win-win
all because Happy was just born
with that little smiley face.
It's so amazing.
Thank you so much, Craig.
Thank you, Happy.
(audience applauds)
I'm liking your post right now.
And that's not all, our
season-long partner, Pilot,
pen makers of G2, the go-to pen
of "The Kelly Clarkson Show"
love how Happy is raising money
to help your local hospital.
And they wanna pitch in as well.
So they're gonna be writing
the West Gibson Land
Healthcare Group a check
for a thousand dollars.
(audience applauds)
- Oh, that's awesome.
Thanks so much.
- Thank you guys so much for joining us
and thanking to all our guests this hour,
Sterling K. Brown, Jaren
Lewison, and Tanya Holland,
Malachi, Miranda and Craig.
Shout out to his little sister,
Malachi's sister, Nevaeh,
that joined us today as well.
Have a happy day y'all.
And if it's not, try and change it.